some battleground states are showing
tightening one of them being florida the
biggest battleground of all
a new poll from nbc and marist
has it very tight essentially tied
likely voters 48 to 48. if you look
at internals of that poll the latino
vote
you compare the 2016 exit polls
with hillary clinton and donald trump
62-35
clinton getting the latino vote in
florida but in this
poll joe biden at 46 donald trump at 50
percent and that is tracking
some latino numbers in north carolina as
well
one element obviously we always look at
those polls as snapshots and time
but it's interesting to look at them
let's bring in our panel bill bennett
former education secretary host of the
bill bennett show
podcast amy's dotted associate editor at
real clear politics
and matthew connetty founding editor of
the washington free beacon
ab let me start with you looking at that
nbc
marist poll it is interesting to see
that shift in just
a few weeks
well i did always think that the polls
were going to tighten and voters were
going to
kind of come home i think joe biden has
seen these really good polling
numbers for months but his campaign
expected that
uh interest and engagement on the other
side was going to
be heightened uh around this time and
that they would have to be prepared
for a tightening race i think if you're
the trump campaign
you just have to contest everywhere you
can
with all the force and ability that you
can because you're behind i think if
you're the biden campaign you have to do
what they've
been saying for months they're going to
do which is defend minnesota new
hampshire
new mexico and nevada not be seduced by
texas and georgia and then look to pick
up
places like north carolina and florida
so they're more cautious than people
give them credit for
but it's still going to be a very
volatile time between now and election
day
yeah we've got those what-if scenarios
on the map that will uh play out over
the next few weeks bill
if this is true and the the trump
campaign is picking up
latino voters in places like florida and
north carolina if they are moving the
needle
in the in the black vote by one two
three points
uh in some of those states that really
could turn the tide
yeah i understand if you go from eight
points and
from the black community which was last
time to 11 or 12
that trump wins the movement
among hispanic voters latino community
is dramatic
yeah i agree with ap i think the thing
is tightening but it's also heating up
but it's getting a kind of intensity now
that uh sometimes it's just reserved for
october the other thing is
you know again from sports i learned in
washington you're on offense if you're
on defense
trump's on offense and joe biden's on
defense
trump the schedule i mean this let's
remember this guy's what 72
this is a herculean schedule that donald
trump keeps
with no sign of slowing slowing down
biden on the other hand seems to be
laboring
not to belabor a point others have made
but you know you're on offense you're on
defense and he's very much on offense
and i think that is a very good thing
the other thing is we are so
roiled as a country in terms of violence
splits
divisions i think that the firmness of
trump
his strength whatever people may think
of his
occasional solacisms may bring moderates
and
people in the middle back to donald
trump they want some
you know some certain captain here even
if he curses from time to time
i don't mean trump does but a captain
does uh and
in stormy seas matthew what about
that schedule you know you see the
president stopping at two states today
and you see the former vice president
joe biden taking the day
off the campaign trail no events for
biden or harris today we were kind of
surprised when we saw that
that the lid for the press was on by
midday
well there are two very different
candidates brett modeling two different
types of campaigns the president trying
to demonstrate that america is back
that we're putting the pandemic behind
us biden's still very much
believing that we need to take steps to
contain and then suppress the virus
a few things about the tightening though
i think it's very important
when we consider that this election in
2016 was decided by
fewer than 100 000 votes in three states
it can be a very narrow margin can have
decisive results in the electoral
college and i think we're looking right
now in these polls
at something very similar happening not
in three states
but maybe in six and that could lead to
a very prolonged post-election
the other thing i'd note is that with
the hispanic vote i think
if trump should win this election the
democratic national convention will be
seen as a missed opportunity for the
biden harris ticket
it had very little to say to latino
voters
and there's this misconception that
latino voters vote solely on immigration
that is not the case what's more
important to them is the economy
and trump's economic message i think is
more powerful than joe biden well we
should also point out in florida they're
playing the
don't vote socialist uh and and the
socialist kind of ad
to the the cuban american and uh puerto
rican-american
communities a b the money game joe biden
raising a lot of money in recent weeks
total raise 328 million total spent 229
million
and you take a look at the cash on hand
there roughly about 100 million dollars
the president big raise 414 but a huge
spend and a big story about
the spending on that 301 million but
cash on hand a little bit more
the president even going so far as
saying he'd put his own money
in this race uh up to whatever he needs
to spend
well let's have this discussion after
the election bretton see if he actually
ever came up with his own money i doubt
that he intends to do that but
um this is a this is a a troubling story
for them because
you and everyone on this panel and i
have talked to republican donors who
have expressed concerns in the summer
months
about the spending the disorganization
the just
the grifting that's gone on and just
spent almost a billion dollars to not
even still really have a message um
has been a source of a lot of tension
on the republican side um and a lot of
concern about the senate majority and
whether donors should just support the
senators and not the president's
uh presidential campaign so he's
a lot of battlegrounds right do you know
how much mitch mcconnell has raised
no i don't i think there's it's a
staggering number too but we're going to
get that
it's it's but mitch mcconnell's aligned
super pac doesn't want to be spending 5
million in kansas right now they have a
lot of money to spend
i mean they have a lot of expense on the
senate republican side they have
many many races where they the
republican might win but they have to
play defense and do a lot of spending so
they need a lot of money and they've
been very frustrated with the fact that
the presidential
campaign and trump align super pacs have
been hoovering up all this money for
years
and their majorities now um you know in
question but i just want to quickly say
about tv ads so trump is down in
battleground states
in tv ads for september going to get
back in october we'll see later on how
effective tv ads are
remember that trump has been up on
youtube and facebook for
many many years now running a general
election campaign on those social media
platforms all along
long before there was a democratic
nominee so we're going to look back and
have to assess
how powerful tv ads are in 2020 as we
always do
panel thank you